[Musique]
mais quand je rentrais sur le territoire
maintenant c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
spécial
2 t'isoler voulait manade martini abete
parlait de mai par la police
quelles que soient les relations entre
l'hydro et le gouvernement
le lancement des travaux de la baie
james en 1971 change profondément le
destin de milliers de travailleurs
québécois
nelson desrosiers débarque au chantier
de lg 3 en février 1976 qu'avant
d'arriver au bout du chemin qui a
complété on s'est fait des idées on sait
faire aider par un tracteur qui nous
attirait un boulot ramené jusqu'au quand
ils ont défendu le jour les hommes
assemble la machinerie à l'extérieur le
soir ils dorment sous une tente
en attendant l'installation déroule de
campements dans le mot janvier où les
dalles de béton puis nous on faisait
réparation d or avec des sautes de
motoneige cet hiver l'eau on a eu des
voix de -54 jurés pendant presque deux
minutes ça c'était quelque chose cafu dû
s'adapter
c'était spécial la main d'oeuvre sur les
chantiers provient de toutes les régions
du québec
mais toutes proportions gardées ce sont
les travailleurs de la gaspésie et du
bas-saint-laurent qui sont les plus
nombreux à s'exiler à la baie james
loin de leurs familles sont dix neuf
pour la phase 1 des travaux
vingt pour cent des travailleurs
proviennent de la gaspésie c'était la
façon dont c'était la façon d'aller
chercher un montant d'argent pour
réaliser des rêves que tours exemple
quand je participe la baie james n 16
j'ai acheté ma maison matin 2 pour la
première fois je tends à logements
important pour la baie james j'ai acheté
ma maison puis ma femme a élevé les
trois enfants des entreprises de génie
et de fabrication profitent de ces
grands travaux pour faire leurs
premières armes
c'est le câble sommet à l'atlantique à
rimouski je me rappelle que le montant
de la soumission était un peu plus
élevée que le chiffre d'affaires annuel
de l'année précédente l'entreprise rafle
d'importants contrats pour des travaux
en acier au détriment de l'américaine
jenny bornes électriques et de la
française alstom la salle à dessein
s'est agrandie plusieurs fois il y avait
énormément d'emplois disponibles et de
bons emplois
robert bourassa marque des points avec
les travaux de la baie james
il voulait entre autres éviter l'exode
des talents québécois au sud de la
frontière
[Musique]
les relations de travail sont toutefois
entachées par le saccage de la baie
james
une guerre intersyndicale éclate sur le
chantier de lg2 le campement et
vandalisé et le chantier est évacué ah
ouais on s'est fait claire l'avion est
normalement monde nelson tremblay se
rappelle encore de l'ambiance qui
régnait à l'époque
c'est toutefois avec retenue qu'il en
parle parce que l'union était forte et
prend la bonne voie d'origine après 20
ans de carrière jean roland lebrun est
maintenant mère dans son village natal
fews se réadapter à vue avec la famille
puis de compenser tout le temps qu'on
était absent une fois de plus il se
retrouve au coeur du développement
énergétique
mais cette fois ci ils planchent sur des
projets éoliens je suis fier parce que
j'ai été chercher des connaissances et
des capacités que je peut redonner sur
les milliers de travailleurs qui ont
construit la baie james 500 0 duc cibles
ont participé à toutes les phases de
construction du complexe à grande
et il disait mitage mais oui je
reconnais jack thompson pour y penser du
boîtier à bord affective or qui va
exister des centaines d'années tout
voyait pas trop fait remonter le moral
wae tion il veut contribuer à la
richesse de temps de ton pays est
importante sol